Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new first look video about batman in the
flash movie they've been filming for a while so
we finally have a look at michael keaton's batman
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll
be doing videos for the movie they'll be filming
for a while so this will be going on for the next
couple of months but if you have no idea what's
going on andy muschietti the director has been
posting a lot of behind the scenes pictures from
the set as they continue to film michael keaton
has been on the set for a while now like they
refer to them as barry allen and bruce wayne on
set because michael keaton will be filming scenes
as bruce wayne and as batman but if you haven't
been following the news the real big deal is that
michael keaton is coming back as his version of
batman from the tim burton movies we're sort of
calling that the burton verse because they're
doing a flashpoint inspired story for the story
of the flash movie it won't be exactly like the
comic book story but they're introducing more of
a legit multiverse during the actual movie so it's
ezra miller's flash traveling from the earth
the justice league movies take place on to the
earth where tim burton's batman movies took place
and that's where we meet michael keaton's batman
and he sort of aged himself into an early batman
beyond aged bruce wayne like a 60-something bruce
wayne even though technically he was 80 during
the events of the batman beyond series you get
the idea he just meant to be a much older grayer
version of batman but still very much batman the
costume picture that everyone's talking about this
week is of his new costume but it's made to look
like a more advanced more hardcore version of his
classic tim burton batman suit from batman returns
this sort of plays into the timeline of the movie
where he's at when the story of the movie begins
so they explained for the purposes of his batman
in the timeline of dc movies right now where the
flash movie takes place they're treating his
batman as if he's coming off of the events
of batman returns like what happened in the
last 30 years since the end of batman returns
and they're pretending like batman forever and
batman and robin in all the other batman movies
since then took place in other universes so
even though you have this continuity with
the same alfred across a couple different batman
like you val kilmer george clooney coming along
they're treating it as if those versions of
batman are from other universes so when we
meet michael keaton he will not have experienced
the events of batman forever in batman and robin
which i think is the smart way to go like we'll
just deal with the continuity from the first two
tim burton batman movies and just treat everything
else like it's multiverse so that's why you see
them filming scenes at the old wayne manor from
his batman movies if you didn't recognize that
this is his way manor from those first two films
but you can see the chest plate lines here look
almost exactly like the second version of his suit
from batman returns that was the movie where they
teased the vault of many different suits because
it was a sequel and they only had the one suit
in the first batman 1989 movie it was a little
more lightweight even though michael keaton said
he was never able to turn his head sideways in it
because of the way they constructed the cow like
it was actually kind of hard for him to film in he
didn't really like filming in the actual suit that
much even though he did enjoy playing batman later
batman movies tried to fix that problem and they
kind of made jokes about it during the christopher
nolan era batman movies like during the dark night
when he's getting his new upgraded suit they have
that very specific scene with lucious fox calling
it out where he says oh you want to be able to
turn your head the whole idea being that they
created more weak points with the seams allowing
villains more targets to pierce the armor or stab
him so when you're talking about batman suits the
whole trade-off is do you want to be able to take
more of a beating or do you want to be more nimble
just depends on what kind of fight you're walking
into that's why michael keaton's batman in batman
returns starts the movie in the original suit from
the first movie but then catwoman almost guts him
with her metal claws so when he comes back again
he's wearing the upgraded armor with the thicker
plating and that's kind of what this new batman
suit looks like like a futuristic version of
what that more armored suit from batman returns
would have become given another 30 years these
darker black lines radiate out from the cymbals
seem like they're more structural reinforcements
in the batman symbol itself in the chest plate
also seems way more hardcore but the symbol is
meant to be the exact same symbol so you know
instantly which batman you're looking at there was
some talk last year that his new suit during the
movie would be something akin to a kingdom come
looking armor suit which isn't quite the same
thing as ben affleck's frank miller inspired
tank looking suit from the dark knight returns
zack snyder was just going for more of a frank
miller inspired look for his ben affleck version
of batman that's why during the justice league
snyder cut in that epilogue scene they actually
do the legit tank from the dark knight returns
the batman suit from kingdom come was a little
bit leaner but the idea was because in that
future timeline of kingdom come batman's body
had just suffered so many injuries he could barely
stand without the help of a mech suit so he walked
around with a special harness base layer that just
helped him get around and wore a much larger armor
suit on top of that when he was acting as batman
but i don't think they're going full kingdom come
in the movie they kind of got into this with
the kevin conroy version of batman during crisis
on infinite earths that was meant to be sort
of an amalgam kingdom come version of batman
i did a big deleted scenes video for that
because originally that part was written for
michael keaton himself the producers of the show
said they went to him but he turned them down so
a lot of the concept art for crisis on infinite
earth features michael keaton batman in a kingdom
come harness but the other real big things
people have been talking about with this big
teaser is the blood splatter and the fact that the
batman suit itself seems like it's covered in dust
but a lot of people were talking about watchmen
after they saw this because it does give off a
very batman flash button crossover vibe with the
comedians button from the watchman movies in the
iconic blood splatter from the watchman comics if
you never read that flash batman button crossover
story it was a prequel meant to set up the
watchmen doomsday clock storyline where superman
fought dr manhattan for the fate of the multiverse
if you didn't realize watchmen became part of the
dc universe a long time ago when dc bought the
watchman comics from alan moore but dc did a big
crossover event with all those characters and it
started with dc rebirth the button storyline with
batman finding the comedian's bloody button from
the watchman comics was just the next big part
of that and they did it as a detective crossover
story with the flash and batman teaming up because
the flash by trade is a crime scene investigator
and batman is the world's greatest detective so
there was all this weird stuff that was happening
batman finds this bloody button they don't know
what it means so they do all this detective
work but while this is happening reverse flash
also shows up in the batcave and beats the crap
out of batman it was a really cool scene but that
doesn't necessarily mean we're going to see a ton
of watchmen stuff going on in this new flash movie
maybe a few minor easter eggs from the multiverse
like we saw in crisis on infinite earths they had
a quick blink and you'll miss it watchman easter
egg on a billboard when constantine takes them
to lucifer's earth on earth 666 because he's the
devil you get the joke but my early theory here
for why the suit looks like it's covered in dust
and has the new blood splatter on it is because it
might just be inside his batcave michael keaton's
batcave hanging up collecting a lot of dust over
the years like he hasn't worn this particular suit
in a long time but when the flash or someone one
of the villains maybe of the movie shows up inside
his bat cave michael keaton's batman probably gets
into a fight with them or something happens he
spills some new blood on this old dusty suit
but it is meant to be new fresh blood on an old
dusty suit they haven't confirmed who the actual
main villain of the flash movie is they're doing a
version of flashpoint and obviously reverse flash
was the main villain of that story but there
was talk last year that because they're already
changing so much about that classic flashpoint
story like it won't be the exact same story they
weren't going to go straight to reverse flash as
the main villain of this first new flash movie
they'd save him for the sequels i'm not expecting
them to actually post any footage of michael
keaton himself running around in an actual batman
costume till like way later this year there is a
big dc fandom event happening later this year that
might be when we get the first legit big teaser
trailer that's also probably when matt reeves
is going to release a new trailer for the batman
movie because that's coming out in march and this
whole dc fandom event is happening in the fall
and even though i didn't talk about him during
this video ben affleck is coming back in the
flash movie he's the one that's actually making
the flash's new suit that they sort of teased in
that concept teaser at the beginning of this they
released that at dc fandom last year so he will be
getting a new flash costume and if you couldn't
tell the special intro like the teaser that they
dropped earlier that i put at the beginning of
this too with the logo reveal that's also made to
be like a version of what his costume is going to
look like with all that speed force energy arcing
all over it in those patterns so there will be
some continuity from the end of the justice league
movie like we just had the justice league snyder
cut and even though technically the epilogue isn't
supposed to be canon to the future dc movies
so i'm not expecting a whole lot of that to be
referenced during the flash movie most of the
events of justice league are still canon so for
the most part like if you just pretend like them
defeating dark side here like them seeing him and
then them going off if you pretend like that's the
end of the film everything that happens up to then
is still canon i know i haven't talked much
about supergirl in the flash movie because
they are introducing a new version of supergirl
and it's based on what seems like henry cavill's
superman because they held up the same suit they
held up henry cavill's superman costume when they
were revealing this new supergirl so it sounds
like they're implying that she might come from
the main justice league earth so it'll be fun to
see how they try to explain where she's been this
whole time but as for the future michael keaton's
older batman in the dc movies the idea was i think
when they signed him they signed him for multiple
films there was talk about him showing up during
a batgirl film they did announce that but that
movie is actually going straight to hbo max and it
sounds like it's going to be a little bit smaller
there was also talk about them eventually doing
a legit batman beyond movie nobody from warner
brothers has really said much about that or the
idea of terry mcginn is showing up but the other
idea was that he would serve as a mentor figure
in bigger justice league crossover films where you
have multiple justice league characters showing up
i don't know if they ever plan to cross over
robert pattinson's version of batman for the most
part matt reeves said that he's kind of working in
his own small universe of earth 2 for the events
of his batman movies they're going to be using
the flash movie to sort of make sense of all these
different disparate movies and different versions
of the characters but everyone let me know in the
comments what do you think about michael keaton
batman in the flash movie what are you most hyped
up to see i just can't wait to actually see him
on screen being batman again something i never
thought that we were ever going to see there's a
whole bunch of really big stuff coming up they're
in the middle of filming a couple big dc movies so
of course i'll be doing videos for all that stuff
my loki episodes are going to start posting next
week so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss anything everyone click
here for that brand new shazam 2 teaser trailer
video and easter eggs and click here for all
my brand new loki videos in my brand new thor 4
first look video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!